et parmi les participants au sky
business de l'entreprise euros
composants dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui avec son directeur
général nous allons parler de son
activité et des problématiques liées à
la pénurie de composants électroniques
et son directeur général c'est julien
berger bonjour bonjour enchanté
alors heureux composants qu'est ce que
c'est
recomposant c'est une société qui fait
de la distribution de composants
électroniques on a différents types de
composants on a des semi conducteurs
nous avons également des modules à
partir de ces semi conducteurs qui
peuvent être des modules d'affichage des
modules de communication sans fil des
calculateurs
des alimentations et nous signons des
accords de partenariat avec des sociétés
étrangères
les fabricants sont essentiellement
localisés en asie ça va être le japon
taïwan la chine et la corée et notre
mission c'est de les commercialiser sur
le territoire français mais également
dans les produits dans les pays
manufacturier de nos clients français
qui sont l'europe de l'est le
maghreb et l'asie du sud-est ont donc on
ça représente à peu près 35 % de notre
activité vous êtes situé à boiser le
bretonneux ça fait 30 ans que vous êtes
situés ici où vous étiez avant ailleurs
alors l'entreprise a commencé il ya 30
ans à saint cloud mais au bout de deux
ans elle a migré sur saint-quentin pas
dans ses locaux là parce que la société
était un peu plus petit il y avait cinq
personnes c'était à 500 m d'ici et donc
dans ses locaux ça fait maintenant une
dizaine d'années
qu'on y est installée on accueille à peu
près 50 personnes pour un chiffre
d'affaires d'un peu plus de 60 millions
d'euros est derrière vous avez des
exemples de ce que vous pouvez proposer
notamment à vos clients alors c'est un
un panel extrêmement réduit
donc il ya des cartes électroniques de
ce type et
il y en a des plus gros cela il s'agit
d'un contrôleur de dalles tactiles donc
c'est des choses qui peuvent être
implémentées dans un autre bouc
notamment mais pour des applications
plus industrielles ici on a des semi
conducteurs donc le composant encapsulés
dans des boîtiers donc on va avoir des
boîtiers en montage de surfaces ou des
boîtiers en picot et est ici vous avez
donc des puces électroniques qui sont
déjà des coupes et donc ce qu'ils sont
des bouts de wever qui sont découpées
suivant la taille du composant et qui
vont dans ces boîtiers là et alors la
pénurie on voit un phénomène mondial
aujourd'hui à une pénurie sur les
composants électroniques et notamment
les semi conducteurs ces semi
conducteurs là qui sont concernés par
par la pénurie
exactement donc là le premier la
première pénurie elle elle affecte les
les wever dans lequel on va fabriquer
ces puces et la concrètement l'impact
sur votre société c'est quoi par rapport
à cette pénurie
c'est de gérer des crises puisque donc
on a pas mal de clients qui sont en
chômage technique
en arrêt de production
c'est des composants qui coûte plus cher
pour pouvoir
accéder à ces composants dans des délais
qui sont raisonnables
quand on dit raisonnable c'est 30 40
semaines alors qu'il ya deux ans on
était plutôt dans les huit à douze
semaines mais 30 à 40 semaines c'est
mieux que pas de composants du tout et
sur certains composants on est au delà
de 50 dos mais nous voir sans semaines
de délais de livraison et justement on
va ensuite descendre au niveau
logistique oui parce que vous avez du
stock finalement malgré cette pénurie on
y va tout de suite
[Musique]
et nous avons rejoint alain refus veille
bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le manager logistique chez
euro composants alors ici on est dans un
atelier qu'est ce qui s'y passe
concrètement ici alors ici c'est
l'atelier d'intégration en fait un des
métiers de recomposant c'est de proposer
à des clients des solutions custom qui
permettent justement de venir mettre à
jour différents procès sur des produits
qui sont vendus donc des écrans des
cartes etc c'est le cas par exemple ici
en fait c'est exactement donc on vient
rajouter un moment donné des cartes
mémoire pour pouvoir répondre à un
cahier des charges client c'est ce qui
fait que le produit n'est véritablement
dédié
et ensuite on a toute une phase de
contrôle qui est fait c'est à dire que
l'on réalise des petites et moyennes
séries et on vient ensuite très emballé
le produit faire les fiches de contrôle
l'a certifié et ensuite ça repart en
logistique pour pouvoir être expédiés eh
bien on va aller dans le magasin à
l'imprimé c'est parti
[Musique]
donc ici c'est un magasin il faut à peu
près 500 m² il ya 3000 références
environ qui sont stockés des références
des toutes petites pièces que vous
pouvez voir ici
qui sont à chaque fois étiquetés avec
codes-barres et toutes les informations
nécessaires et ensuite c'est sont ces
mêmes pièces d'ailleurs une petite
parenthèse qu'on va retrouver à
l'atelier d'intégration que nous avons
vu précédemment et qui vont nous
permettre d'alimenter tous ces
différents chantiers donc ici les flux
qui sont traités c'est environ une
cinquantaine de commandes par jour ça
représente 60 colis en termes d'activité
c'est principalement des clients qui
sont en france y aussi des clients à
l'export et donc nous avons tout le
matériel qu'il faut pour pouvoir traiter
les expéditions les factures les
certificats de conformité et autres
documents nécessaires concrètement sur
la partie logistique comment vous est
impacté par la pénurie d'offre de semis
composants et enfin de semi conducteurs
et de composants électroniques alors
l'impact il est réel parce qu'à un
moment donné on a des commandes clients
qui sont en attente ce qui est sûr c'est
que derrière les coudes approches ont
énormément augmenté
ça veut dire que pour pouvoir traiter
des imports régulièrement avec
l'inflation qu'il ya eu sur toute la
partie du transport on est tenu
néanmoins de faire venir ces pièces et
on a des coûts d'acquisition qui sont
extrêmement importants et impact est
donc en termes de quantité de pièces on
en a moins ils sont aussi plus cher à
faire venir d'une difficulté de très pro
logistique dans la suite des opérations
et finalement vous maintenez quand même
une activité parce que il ya une grosse
demande face à cela oui oui tout à fait
au maintien en activité parce que
recomposant a du stock c'est aussi la
force du distributeur c'est de pouvoir
répondre à ces exigences clients donc
bien évidemment mais aussi un
ralentissement de l'activité il ya
néanmoins du stock qu'il permet de tenir
et de traiter les commandes comme il se
doit mais ce n'est pas toujours facile
on a des délais qui sont passés de 50 à
60 70 semaines sur certains produits
donc oui c'est compliqué merci à la
réveille
manager logistique chéreau composants et
le sky échos se poursuit ici même à
voisins le bretonneux